do you feel like people are surprised to
learn that you aren't this like cloud of
sorrow with all the melancholy songs
that people might be familiar with you
actually have a sense of humor yeah
maybe I think so I don't think yes it's
nothing as something I never thought
about for a long time like I never
thought oh I'm sorry sad songs on it'd
be a big sad guy but yeah I just that's
only something I realized after the
music came out and people started to
fade minutes ago and be like all this
guy's not you know a big sad loser all
the time - I mean it's that lose it all
the time but sometimes happy I'm sure I
mean air and I thank him yeah it was it
was a very strange but no one's like one
emotion all the time I think I've been
to see bands and sang elsewhere and
between songs topical you know this next
song is about a girl you know who broke
my heart it's just like sha gayle Cygnus
song we paid to see you sang it and
normal it's about at a pop song gave me
it gave me at both battles so I don't I
don't really think about hmm I don't
know think about me in terms of like
these are the song season this is who I
am as a as a as a man pretty small as to
scale and there yeah I just think of
just I just do it I mean I just sing a
song but I love the music and I love the
way they are promoting it and I want to
talk about your tinder account because
like oh yeah what the sinner can do you
active tuner was that all marketing no
no no I've had to ever attend the
Goldmember for quite some time so no
some people may say that sad I would
agree right but I think I yeah I've had
it fought no it's not sad it's sad
because I've never actually been on a
tender date so I've just had tender gold
and just been sweeping my life away
sweepin sweepin sweepin that says how
what I've been doing my entire life just
given us weight getting us weight and
then people will message me around
message them and nothing ever comes
about that's the sad part
so no I think my tender use has been as
been purely for self esteem so like if
someone likes my picture to me I'm like
I must be must be so handsome but then
every but conversely if someone doesn't
I felt nervous if I see someone I think
you will be my wife Joe I mean sometimes
you fall in love with a picture and a
bio barely really but and I go poop of a
book I go we're gonna leave you're gonna
be the mother of my children so I pray
the next day nowhere to be seen nowhere
to be seen
okay if k23 from knowledge there's
nowhere to be seen
but yeah I've been a I've been a tender
boy a tender boy that's the new thing
we'll try push and abettor tender user a
very long time so yeah when that when
that came up I mean I'm not gonna put a
jump at the chance
also three tender gold for life dating
like must be better now with the
successes happen if you would you would
think so wouldn't you
you would think so but no it's movin I
mean I definitely I don't have as much
time maybe it would be I was much tight
so I mean before I was you know
longingly looking a nap just hoping and
praying that the gods would send me a
lovely lady to sway pray on and no I
just will have the tape I don't have a
time to sleep as much as I wanted else
wait I still spent vigorously when I got
of course when I got a moment to myself
I'm having a swipe I'm having a big
sweep but yeah it's not it's not as I
was always told your world you got the
cliche you watch these documentaries you
know once you get there soon
girls love musicians right okay that's
okay that's not so I play guitar a mess
hanging over me not doesn't work it
doesn't seem to work it may be as
successful musicians know curate yeah
what were their hard to master nowhere
to be seen so it's not it's not I would
say I wouldn't look I'm not saying I'm
like never cast to get all in my life
sure I mean I'm not you know I mean I'm
not I'm locust one or two gay levels
I've kissed more than that I'm not I'm
not kidding Eddie yeah I mean but I am
ya know it's a it's definitely noise the
night's get lonely I get cold and I'm
getting my bed energy glass
I'm holding myself I'm holding my arms
and I'm cradling mice
I'm coming I'm just spending time just
being single that's good yeah cradling
their money based on the success you're
having with someone you love yeah maybe
that song has just catapulted you into
the ultimate spotlight thank you but I
know because I have worked at ICI
nephrons 12 years like when these
artists and these songs hit yeah they're
not just yours they're everyone's and
you're expected to play that song and
perform that song every single night
show appearance every concert and every
opportunity need somebody on the street
they want to hear that song yeah how do
you feel about that song now and are you
starting to is it starting to grow
tiring to have to provide all the time
no because every time I sing it I just
think of the money the money I'll get
this thing yeah we go no yeah I just
think to ever have a song is done that
is a very strange thing so I'd be about
this is a thing as well the people who
doing sang the buggers songs they don't
sing that bogus songs last the gigs just
shy just do it I mean there should be no
I just like I said that pretentious or
thinking if you like you know this is my
big song and I'm good at shy away from
it you I mean I'm very aware that I've
got one I've got one back really really
a song that's done really well and in 11
other songs on my album that maybe
aren't as good but I think I think yeah
I think it's no it's just there I said
that's a song that people have connected
with the most so Who am I to be like
well I'm gonna play it faster that's it
and I'm not gonna play it at all or get
angry with the water heater I'm just
glad that people wanting him as homes so
I mean when asked when people see you
know all that loose key party song so I
was belched
in the middle of it that loose cappella
song and I'm sick of hearing that that's
on the radio too much I'm hanging yes
charlie I've always wanted that since so
it's a so this is good but people are
loving including like I mean you freaked
out when you saw the live round with God
cannula Camilla Kibeho and obviously you
have not only Keaney was a huge fan but
you have people like Ed Sheeran in your
corner who are massive fans who had you
out with him and I'm I love your
relationship with him it kind of scene
is it they describe that as a bromance
I say romance without the take away the
beat it's just just sweet sweet romance
and
Hey taking over a lot of meals and there
no ahem he yeah he was lovely I really
got on with him and I've really come
looking a lot at these people like who
who've kind of took me under their wing
took me under and there yeah I think
with him yeah it was just it was just
fairly certain been this guy but I mean
every bass the Tigers and music everyone
always says or edge here this Shan a so
totally off and your leg
how nice can it be and you meet me like
oh god you're so lovely no like you're
not rooting for him not to be loved it
but it's just like yeah it's like so
brand-new yeah we just got on very well
and he couldn't even drank alcohol for
sure he can take a lot of alcohol more
than me so yeah we did some of that and
we sang some bloody songs I had a good
old time we held hands and we frolicked
and we we galavant it that was a lovely
time were you surprised because I feel
like now that you're in the sphere think
it's one thing to be an outsider and
look into the sphere of like Fame and
and music business and think okay all it
is it's like I write a song and they
become big and they don't see all the
other things that are associated with it
and all the work that goes into then
sleepless nights doing this on your
weekend
when Ed announced that he was taking a
step back and taking a break like the
internet loss is not yeah and I thought
no it's my chance jump in here while
he's gone can did it at an algal I'll be
next ever I'll be the nice guy
you